it's been a hot and dry summer and
unusually some parts of the uk haven't
had rain in weeks and that's led to
looming fears of drought
drought is essentially a prolonged dry
period that has caused a water shortage
every drought is different depending on
where it is what time of year it is and
the type of environment
this makes it difficult to pin down
exactly when one officially begins
but essentially it's when a lack of
water starts to have a serious effect on
our lives
it can be really damaging in the u.s
drought is the second most costly
weather event after hurricanes there are
four stages normal prolonged dry weather
drought and severe drought with england
currently sitting in the second
prolonged dry weather one
and there are various causes of droughts
including changing temperatures and
weather patterns a higher demand for
water and soil degradation
you have three main types of drought
environmental agricultural and water
supply
environmental drought is when a shortage
of rainfall has an impact on the
environment this could affect the land
wildlife and fish
agricultural drought occurs when there
isn't enough rain to support crop
production and other farming practices
and a water supply drought also known as
a hydrological drought happens when the
dry spell is long enough to seriously
impact water supply this means rivers
reservoirs or groundwater supplies dry
up and is very bad news
[Music]
droughts have happened throughout
mankind's history
so are nothing new
but one of the main causes of drought is
a changing temperature and that is
something we are seeing more and more of
thanks to climate change
climate change is making the weather
more extreme the drier place is drier
and the wetter place is wetter so in
warmer places the water in the land
dries up quicker than it used to
and less water in the soil means more
drought
there are some ways we can try and stop
droughts becoming so common
before the drought starts we can
implement things like hosepipe bans
commercial and residential water
restrictions and we can try to manage
our water more carefully generally we
can also try to recycle water more water
from home is usually sent straight to
the sewer but water from baths showers
washing machines dishwashers and sinks
is known as grey water and is much
easier to recycle
it is estimated this could save 70
liters of water per person per day in
domestic households
on a bigger scale we can also try to
fight climate change preserve more water
improve the water infrastructure around
the world and make our water management
generally much better
but we can't control the weather and
with the world getting hotter droughts
are sadly going to become more and more
common